that reminds me of a thin
George join our show that said fitting
in is death but the other quote sitting
in a what fitting in is death George
Bernard Shaw absolutely but one of the
things that I love about your approach
to life and why you personally but also
your work inspires me is this enthusiasm
that you show and the humor that you
bring to these experiences and some of
these are really tough experiences and
just to drop in another quote you know
Winston Churchill has a saying that I've
also embraced in which he says and also
because I've made so many mistakes in my
own life that success is going from
failure to failure but with enthusiasm
and and that enthusiasm must be part of
your makeup because in some of the
stories about reaching out to people to
get them to invest in snick and to get
raise money to bail students out or
other young kids out of jail who are
being arrested must have taken its toll
on you and yet and yet you brought with
it such a compassion and such such a
humor it is that was that is that part
of your strategy or just part of your
DNA both ah let me give you a quick a
quick example of an experience that will
can maybe tell you how I am required to
greet life during the civil rights
movement when there were you I'd be that
some of the most critical moments in our
confrontation with the system it was
extremely important that we win the
justice system of our country our
government we win it to our cause
because the thing that most oppressed
or the laws that existed the segregation
laws the laws are the racial oppression
the laws of denial the lausitz and I
couldn't go to this school of that
school and this constant machine of
oppression and an alienation required
that we apply the most powerful weapon
we had which were the tenants and the
laws of a constitution what did the law
say what did the Supreme wall say and
although many states practice
segregation the supreme law the federal
law constitution had other
interpretations so it was important to
us to win those who were the
administrators of law administrators of
justice those who manipulated the
language of judgment and when John
Kennedy was president we waited with
great anticipation for who would he
appoint at that of Justice Department
most important agency in government for
us and he appointed his brother Bobby
Kennedy and what little we knew of Bobby
Kennedy suggested to us that was not
going to be a joyous ride a rich very
Irish vary from from a foreign
environment that had no real evidence
and our relationship the people of color
or people who were poor he wasn't a bad
fellow it was just an indifferent fellow
and he wallowed and played in the play
in the lives and the indulgence of the
rich and we were poor and we were
alienated and we were being denied
access to justice and we needed to have
his opinion fall in favor with the
things we were trying to achieve and
when we discussed the fact that that'd
be an impossible task because when he
came to the to the role of attorney
general he had already been a legal
voice for the house on American
Activities Committee which is a very
cruel agency that
a lot of witch-hunting and branded
people unpatriotic and victor of the
villains of uh our pure orders society
and or call communists and things that
were considered to be unfavorable titles
and he was part of that machine he was
part of that that that process and when
he became of tourney general that's how
we saw him so the point of this story is
that giving you that background is that
dr. King and listening to our
evaluations and assessment of him said
to us I've heard anything you had to say
and very little as challengeable except
that he is the Attorney General and we
need him and your task is to go find his
moral Center and win him to our cause so
the mission was more than just how do
you nip you laid him as the
administrative justice and how he would
interpret it yet to study the van and
know more about his humanity and his
taste and his social habits and win him
through a social encounter that took us
off the dime and kept having us relate
to one another based upon our social
experiences or the truth of the matter
is that for those of you who look at the
arc of that history by the end of his
life I don't think there was a voice
that was possessed a more moral power
and more moral clarity than Bobby
Kennedy had he lived and had he become
the president the United States the 21st
century would be an infinitely different
canvas than the one we were experiencing
so winning him winning his humanity
helping to cleanse the process for him
and for us to be able to make a an
exchange for us into a relationship of
mutual joy and mutuality extremely
important the law and the rest of it
became another objective but we did both
and I think in that context a nation
was enhanced considerably by the fact
that Bobby Kennedy and altered and his
brother too in a way although I often
say that history created John Kennedy
more than John Kennedy created history
the system and those are so activists
pushed the Kennedy administration to do
things they would not ordinarily have
done the youth in particular and the
anti-war movement and Vietnam and
women's rights and a lot of host of
racial and social issues were just
brought to the to the surface of human
experience were in the streets were
wherever where you went you came up
against this force for change and the
administration had to deal with us the
politics of their own interests were at
stake and we knew this and we played all
these themes as cleverly as we could as
righteously as we could in it with as
much moral truth as we could summon and
in the end we prevailed I have to say to
the young people a lot of times you know
we never lost a battle in the Civil
Rights moon we never we didn't win the
war the war is still going on and it's a
huge war but we never lost a battle
anything we've set out to do to change
laws to change social perception to
change the way with women were treated
in the south as as of activists in their
own communities are being lawyers of it
you couldn't get a white or black woman
in the south to be a lawyer because the
courts had gender in positions that
denied them the right to practice law
fully so in that sense what we did
changed the way in which America was
thinking albeit we didn't get to the
rest of it as much enthusiasm and
passion as we should have so now we're
trying to pick those pieces up and today
is void and see if we can
yarmouth what we originally set out to
to siphon diesel own lengthy in the
answer